reminds me of this meme right here the
more i the more i learn about this man
the more i respect him the more i i
think he's doing a great job for our
country
and people i have a lot of friends of
mine
i have family members of mine that have
been like
i watch a show and i i can't believe
that i'm actually going to vote for
donald trump this year i'll tell you
what i'm disappointed
in who and what in everything okay i'm
absolutely
disgusted by the democrats i am enraged
by them
okay and i'm disappointed generally that
for me
donald trump is the the only the only
choice right now
yep you know i guess it's kind of like
the saying it reminds me of uh
this old kind of it's not really a joke
it's kind of a joke i think i told it on
the show before but but i'll say it now
it's a it's a religious joke where a guy
is in his house
and a flood starts remember i told you
this one uh let's tell again
check it out it's a guy's in his house
and a flood
starts and there's water sweeping
through the streets the neighbors run to
his house and say quit quit
come out and jump in our car and you
know we need to get out of here and he
goes no no
no i'm going to wait for my lord to save
me and so they say no are you crazy
you have to come with us and he goes i'm
going to pray to the lord to save my
life they leave
the water rises and he runs upstairs he
starts praying again please save me
please save me lord
now a boat pulls up his window and the
guy says hop in the boat quick we're
getting out of here the flood water is
too high and he says no no i'm praying
to the lord to save me
i'm gonna i'm gonna my lord will save me
are you crazy come on he goes
no he leaves the water keeps rising he
climbs on his roof now a helicopter
comes they throw a rope ladder down
quick
climb up before you die and he goes no
i'm praying to the lord to save my life
the helicopter guy says you're crazy but
he refuses the
flood waters rise and the man dies he
goes to heaven
and finally when he gets to speak to his
lord he says i prayed and prayed and
prayed why didn't you save me
and the lord says i sent a truck i sent
a boat and a helicopter you wouldn't
take it
and that's the joke the point is you
think you're going to get a perfect
vision
of what's supposed to come and help you
out of this crisis and i
do i cannot believe that it's come to
the point where two years ago i was
laughing like i'm never gonna vote for
donald trump yeah
now it's so bad with the riots and i kid
you not they arrested
two small business owners only a few
miles from my house
because they wanted to do a small
limited membership only gym
opening yeah a couple handful of people
and so the governor's like
lock them up they're letting prisoners
out of
out of the jails out of the prisons and
they're bringing like 8 000
in california or something like that
some ridiculous amount i'm sorry man
for all of the faults that trump has had
that made me
angry and upset or laugh and like i'm
not you know
now at this point where i'm like what am
i supposed to do vote for biden so i'm
disappointed that i'm that i'm like
i normally wouldn't care to vote for
trump or especially not
biden especially not hillary but i know
that trump is a funny guy
i just could never expect that the the
highest office of our country
would be to a reality tv real estate
mogul comedian
who at least loves the country with an
economics degree
sure you know he's a billionaire he
knows he's a real estate mogul you know
i think he's smart guy i think he's very
successful yep and i
and the reason i told that joke about
you know expecting this perfect solution
to save your problems
is that maybe right now the only thing
we have is trump so for all of the
things that he said or done where i'm
like i roll my eyes and i'm like i would
prefer someone better
at this point what's our choice joe
biden
even joe rogan said it rather vote for
trump than joe biden
you got to think about what joe biden
represents and what's happening in this
country right now
and then it becomes a very very
difficult position it's not easy
absolutely not to be alive for me it is
free i'm voting for trump
not for me it's it's my liberal
sensibilities
sure i i see i see trump and i see a lot
of things that i'm totally fine with
okay i see a lot of things where i think
he's like the easiest thing is character
issues
but for the most part he's absolutely
done a better job on a lot of issues
in the past couple of years but now
we're at a point once he's able to
finally start
doing his job because he hasn't been
hampered down by a certain
of group of people trying to bring him
down i'm i'm
i personally am not confident that
well i'm confident the economy will do
well but i'm i'm
i'm still concerned that under donald
trump presidency there will be a lot of
problems facing
our nation and the world but that's
irrelevant at this point
the nation is crumbling the the
constitution is riddled with holes in
swiss cheese
joe biden is one of the architects of so
much of these problems
the democrats are joining in the chaos
the democratic governors are arresting
people for opening their businesses and
locking down their states and some
republicans too
and so right now i'm like well the
ship's sinking
i guess i'm tossing my hat over to trump
it's probably a good time to invest in
some uh
some gold glass stock glass
yeah oh because of all the replacements
find your local glass company invest
heavily because they're going to be put
in business
yeah so look this meme in reality
they're not after me they're after you
i'm just in the way
i'm like i i believe it
i do trump is in the way can i get my i
don't like him
he's a funny guy i don't like him but
you know what i'm just over here like
well here's here's the main point of all
the problems
do i think the obnoxious bully is going
to make
a you know you know um beautiful and
glorious feature for everybody
excuse me you're trying to use we i
recorded some voices for adam
i have an answer to that excuse me yes
he is
absolutely yes it doesn't matter this is
the more important point
i do not i feel confident the economy
don't get me wrong
but i look at the people he's hired john
bolton
i'm not confident he's going to hire the
right people but it doesn't matter
anymore you know why
because they're literally burning
everything to the ground the alternative
is worse
the alternative is is beyond worse the
the alternative is oblivion
outright oblivion well i i look at that
and it's like
he came into office not as a politician
becoming a politician becoming
the highest honor of the land like the
president of the of america
you know and half of the half of the
government
right off the bat hated him still hates
him still hasn't just
even accepted that he won in 2016 still
to this day
you know and then who knows how many
people they were
being like you know make him look as bad
as possible even if they hire if
if he hires you make him look terrible
let's let's undermine everything we can
to get him out of office
you know now like he brought in bar you
know
i like bar well yeah he's so he's
started you can see it that he's
starting to be like
get into the flow you know of
understanding his powers
you know rex till what is it rex uh rex
tillerson tillerson
talks about how he was kind of sick of
having to tell trump you know look is
what you can't do you
no no he and he said i liked almost
every single
idea that trump had almost all of them
but he was annoyed because trump was
just like why can't we just do this
yep and he would be like because legally
we have to go through all of these
things and trump's like ugh like dude i
just want to i want to fix all this like
let's do this
this so he's had his hands tied behind
his back well no hold on
this is actually a very common problem
with business people
becoming politicians right when you own
your own company you're like i see the
problem
boom fixed right when you're in
government like i see the problem let's
submit to committee
and we'll hear back in three months and
then when half of that committee hates
you
because you ruined their whole pla plans
to
or you're costing them money or same
thing they're stock
as far as these people that's their
plans their plans are money
that's what it is or their re-election
and their their constituents are
screaming
come back to this meme cut cut back to
this meme
now now a little more context it makes
even more sense
because that they're after everybody
they want
and he's just he's just in the way and
now he's learning how to really
use the powers of the president to the
the best of his abilities
i i want to see four years i think he
did
face a learning curve his first time in
in government oh yeah
hiring john bolton was one of the most
laughably stupid things
and he's hired a bunch of really dumb
people i'm hoping i'm hoping
that because the alternative is like
everything burning to the ground
that if trump gets reelected and
republicans take over they're going to
fix several things like section 230
for instance i would love that yeah it's
it's crazy to me and the war on drugs
and the war on drugs bring our troops
back from the middle east yep man
i i just want trump to to walk up on
november 2nd and be like
decriminalizing marijuana federally all
gone
everybody's being released we're good
don't worry we're gonna make sure the
violent ones stay inside i'll be like
all right let's do this i think so many
people he would probably win every
single state
every single vote if he did that
probably what are they gonna do come out
against marijuana legalization
they would they'd try they would
actually trump is wrong because some of
these people
well he made hemp legal and i didn't
know that until i started researching
into him and yeah that's awesome like we
don't have to cut
chop down trees to make paper or clothes
like
hemp makes oh man there's countless
things you can make fuel
out of hemp and it grows like that it's
crazy
i'm not talking about like the people
that smoke thc
weed i'm talking about like an actual
apple paper
cbd cbd hen hemp yeah it's it's
incredible what we can do with that it's
man there's a lot and he did prison
reform i think i think now that he like
he probably
he brought on a bunch of people he
shouldn't have he's getting bad advice
from people
he needs to he needs to get rid of the
bad people
i'd yeah you know but you know what man
at this point in the matter for mix i'm
like
if biden wins biden will be walked all
over by the far left he already is he'll
fall asleep
and then it'll be the obama
administration all over again and people
don't realize the horrific things they
were doing
yeah if you know now that i'm i'm i'm
worried
that there's gonna be a little bait and
switch that true yeah no with trump
oh with trump yeah because he fired the
missiles in syria
he's been doing drone strikes i'm doing
commando raids now but to be fair in the
past couple of years
he's been pulling you know drawing
things down a little bit and who who was
the person that was uh
what he was working with oh yeah both
exactly and who's a warmonger oh yeah
bolton he's the warmonger
the excuse me the warm up i'm hoping
here's my interest
so while he was doing all that no why
while he was doing all that who was the
one that was helping him whispering in
his ear like this is what we need to do
bolton so here's so he was doing all
that here's what i want now
got rid of bolton i just want to finish
this got rid of bolton now what is he
trying to do
bring the troops home so here's what i
want i want trump
to be so angry with john bolton he he
ends all this war
just to spite him because bolton writes
that book and that's ragging him yeah i
want trump to hold a grudge
and be like you cross me oh yeah i'll
pull all our troops back i'll be like
yeah trump you show him
bring our troops back from the middle
east and from syria and from these other
countries where they shouldn't be
right right that'd be amazing yeah i
have friends that are stationed
out in europe right now just in case
yeah i i can't believe
i how many liberal friends i have are
like well the war
actually i'm like great trump's going to
announce he's going to decriminalize pot
and they're going to be like but you
know
there are issues i i would love to hear
their argument for that they did it with
war
yeah they did it with war you know i was
reading this neocon who talked about the
importance of american imperialism and
i'm no no no no no sorry
you can't be mad at trump for firing the
missiles when i agree with you
yeah and then all of a sudden you're mad
at trump when he's pulling him out
because now i disagree with you
what you're doing makes no sense no
principles
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you